and that on youtube it's hard dude it
really is hard yeah now yeah and like i
said our main channel we got this foot
we got the two strikes and it's always
funny because like they every time that
happens you know there'll be people who
might say oh we got another strike but
why are you even on their platform like
we're on five other platforms but you
don't watch us there you're the one that
goes to youtube go watch us on fumble
i'd happily say in rumble or odyssey
like i don't we're everywhere but they
go you're the ones that want us involved
too it's like they're saying it's like
saying go use go go go duck but they
want the chat on youtube they want to
google so we can't it's hard like oh
yeah you should only do it on a rock fan
are only on this paywall service like
nobody's gonna watch it then then i'm
gonna do it to nobody so what's the
people who's gonna care yeah exactly
that's why independent content creators
like y'all like myself i think there's a
huge future for us as long as we don't
get censored as long as you don't get
totally taken out like y'all you just
keep pushing you're going to keep
growing there's nobody that can stop you
and uh
because your content is not it's it's
unfiltered because you're the straight
crack then they're they're they're
putting baking soda in it
yeah they're they're they're one kind of
pure coke
policy